o iPhone wallpaper plena Ponte Estaiada
leite eu vou ver ele é
E você ainda lembra quando era possível
viajar para qualquer destino do mundo
sem se preocupar com máscara álcool gel
distanciamento social ou exame PCR
quando você ia com o aeroporto EA sua
preocupação era que talvez eu vou
poderia ser cancelado por conta de
condições climáticas mas nunca por conta
de fechamento de fronteiras
Ah pois é veio uma pandemia e mudou a
sua forma de fazer turismo e por vezes o
impediu até de fazer turismo Eu costumo
dizer que nem a melhor empresa de
planejamento estratégico prevendo o pior
cenário possível poderia imaginar o que
está acontecendo fronteiras fechadas
Lock Down hotéis impedidos de funcionar
equipamentos de lazer culturais sem
funcionamento
é mas será que nós retomaremos ao
turismo como era antes ou teremos uma
nova forma de fazer turismo para
pensarmos sobre essa pergunta precisamos
retroceder um pouco antes da pandemia o
que estava acontecendo no turismo
Mundial antes destinos como Lisboa
Barcelona praga Veneza estavam sofrendo
com o excesso de turismo com a
massificação O que é chamado de
overtures eu mesma como pesquisadora em
fevereiro de 2020 exatamente duas
semanas antes de ser decretada pandemia
e nem imaginar o que aconteceria
protocolei um projeto para concorrer a
uma bolsa de pesquisa com o tema
overtures na cidade do Porto em Portugal
adivinhem só quando sair o resultado em
novembro de 2020 eu não foi contemplada
com bolsa nem
é porque esse tema já não era relevante
Nessa altura Mas voltando ouvertures
vamos tomar como exemplo a cidade de
Veneza na Itália uma cidade com 60 mil
habitantes que recebia anualmente 20
milhões de turistas os residentes já
estavam a rejeitar o turismo o turismo
já não estava a ser algo positivo para a
cidade por alguns motivos um deles é que
os aluguéis eram tão caros e o custo de
vida tão alto os residentes já não
viviam na sua cidade Mas viviam nos
arredores outro é a questão ambiental os
canais completamente poluídos outras
cidades também vinham sofrendo com a
questão dos Altos preços dos aluguéis
por quê Porque grandes investidores
compravam blocos de prédios ou compravam
todos os prédios dos centros históricos
re formavam para transformá-los
o local e colocar luz em plataformas
como o book e Air BNB alguns autores
chamam isso de sol Silas bairro e sem
alma porque nós não temos mais ali
residentes circulando pela rua não temos
mais alma do Residente somente turistas
entrando e saindo desses prédios
é algo a ser discutido também nesse
momento do Turismo era de que forma
estava sendo conduzido o turismo
cultural Será que turismo cultural é
somente ir ao Museu do Louvre ficar na
ponta do pé atrás de uma multidão que
está fotografando a Monalisa eu mesmo me
questionei muito sobre o turismo
cultural quando estive numa ocasião numa
igreja na cidade do Porto também em
Portugal uma igreja Lindíssima por sinal
quando eu abrir a porta eu não vi a
lindeza da igreja mas somente uma
multidão de pessoas com seus smartphones
fotografando as imagens
Oi e aí eu me questionei será que eles
estão aqui vivendo uma experiência
cultural histórica e até espiritual ou
estão só registrando esse momento para
mostrar depois
e Em contrapartida nós tínhamos uma
realidade de um lado eles são realidades
modificada e de outro lado uma realidade
de pequenos destinos que não tinham
políticas adequadas para atrair a
demanda e por isso tinham pouca demanda
E aí a pandemia e é certo que isso
impactou sobremaneira o turismo e nenhum
outro momento histórico mesmo já tendo
momentos em que o turismo foi impactado
como caso é do 11 de setembro outros
momentos epidêmicos como H1 N1 e a bola
nenhum desses momentos impactaram tanto
como o covid-19 segundo dados da
Organização Mundial do Turismo no espaço
de um ano 87 por cento das chegadas
internacionais foram reduzidas em abril
de 2020 96 por cento dos destinos
mundiais tinham alguma restrição a
viagens
Oi e aí começou a se pensar e agora o
turismo Será que nós teremos uma
retomada do Turismo O que fazer para
retomar o vez turismo Existem várias
várias pessoas estudando isso nós
pesquisadores temos algumas alternativas
estamos a pensar em algumas alternativas
e Estas são ideias que valem a pena ser
compartilhadas
a primeira questão a ser compartilhada é
que chegou o momento de se preocupar
ainda mais com as questões da
sustentabilidade qualquer ação que
envolva o turismo deve pensar e permear
as questões da sustentabilidade e até a
analisar os objetivos do desenvolvimento
sustentável da ONU agora é o momento
também de incentivar o turismo doméstico
turismo interno uma vez que as
fronteiras muitas fronteiras ainda estão
fechadas EA Nossa ânsia de viajar é
muito grande Diante de tudo que estamos
passando e vivendo é o momento de
incentivar que conheçamos que você
conhece o seu país a sua cidade o seu
estado tantas belezas escondidas
pertinho de você que muitas vezes você
nem sabe é o momento de você descobrir e
é um momento
o IOS é decisores os planejadores do
Turismo Buscar planos de incentivos para
que as pessoas viagem eternamente
obviamente Todas as viagens nesse
momento e daqui para frente é ter uns
cada vez mais a preocupação sanitária os
turistas buscam a sua segurança
sanitário e Os destinos devem mostrar a
sua preocupação com estas questões de
saúde cada vez mais alguns destinos Como
Portugal Já lançou o selo clique em save
para mostrar isso Brasil também tem
alguns selos para mostrar a questão da
preocupação sanitária
a e agora eu quero compartilhar com você
algo que pode ser um grande lance para
retomada do Turismo Principalmente nos
pequenos destinos como eu falei que
estavam a sofrer com a atração de
demanda no período pré pandêmico
Qual é a modalidade de turismo criativo
como eu questionei Aquele modelo de
turismo cultural também massificado o
turismo criativo vai no oposto do
Turismo Criativo o turista Deixa de ser
o agente passivo da sua viagem e ele
passa a ser o agente ativo existe um
envolvimento forte entre turistas e
residentes O Turista deixa de
simplesmente comprar um suvenir para
levar para sua casa mas ele passa a
produzir esses o verniz ele passa a
saber como faz o prato típico ou trocar
alguns passos de dança típica com o
residente o residente passa a ser um
importante papel no processo de
desenvolvimento do Turismo o turismo
criativo tem muito forte o aspecto da
criação e da transformação é a coleção
de experiências é cocriar a sua
experiência
e agora pensem comigo que grande
oportunidade tem o Brasil com pequenos
destinos com lugares tão autênticos
singulares que podem proporcionar
diferentes experiências criativas para
os turistas são é agora é o momento de
transformação é um momento de quebra de
paradigmas podemos aproveitar esse
momento em que tudo parou por uma grande
retomada uma retomada mais criativa mais
sustentável entre os turistas coleciona
em experiências e não só a paz em todos
os locais e depois digam que passaram
mais vivam efetivamente os locais vivam
a cidade compartilhem com os residentes
as experiências e os residentes mostrem
a sua importância assim é possível o
desenvolvimento local sustentável
garantindo que as comunidades permaneçam
o território
esse é o momento de uma grande
transformação é um momento talvez de
turistas como Novo Olhar edestinos.com
novo planejamento atraindo esse turista
com um novo olhar por isso eu quero que
você pense na experiência que você quer
colecionar na sua próxima viagem em que
destino você quer estimular a sua
criatividade e criar e destinos é o
momento de planejar o que vocês querem
ofertar diferente para esses turistas
quais experiências vocês querem deixar
viva na memória dos turistas Afinal o
turismo é uma atividade super importante
e essencial e vamos combinar tudo de bom